[Musik]
drama in nordhessen ein autofahrer rast
absichtlich in einen karnevalsumzug es
gibt viele verletzte
die cdu in der krise die partei wählt
bereits am 25
april auf einem sonderparteitag den
nachfolger von cdu-chefin kramp
karrenbauer und corona virus in europa
in italien spitzt sich die lage zu auch
in deutschland rechnet
gesundheitsminister sparen mit einer
ausbreitung des virus
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick
norbert könig ist auch dabei für den
sport oder namen
es ist ein schock mitten im bunten
karnevalstreiben in nordhessen ist ein
junger mann absichtlich mit hoher
geschwindigkeit in die zuschauer eines
rosenmontagsumzugs gefahren warum ist
noch völlig offen
30 menschen darunter auch kinder sind
verletzt sieben schwer
volkmarsen ist eine kleinstadt mit knapp
7000 einwohnern rund 30 kilometer
nordwestlich von kassel
der wagen war gegen halb drei in die
menge gerast und dann so berichten
zeugen noch etwa 30 meter weiter
gefahren
andrea meuser berichtet sekunden nach
dem zwischenfall
der silberfarbene mercedes steht am
straßenrand die frontscheibe zerstört
der rosenmontagsumzug hatte gerade
begonnen da zur berichten des
augenzeugen fährt das auto mit hoher
geschwindigkeit in eine menschenmenge
der fahrer soll bewusst eine absperrung
umfahren haben dann sei er auf die
feiernden zugerast bekam ein auto von
oben runter durch die straße in voller
geschwindigkeit oder festzug war und in
die menge reingefahren mit voller
geschwindigkeit das sind viele bürger
steigt da gelegen kinder und haben die
mütter haben geschrien und die kinder
haben dort das war furchtbar 30 menschen
sollen verletzt sein davon sieben schwer
unter ihnen eben viele kinder bei dem
fahrer soll es sich um einen deutschen
aus der region handeln er wurde
festgenommen
ist aber nicht vernehmungsfähig er soll
stark alkoholisiert gewesen sein
die generalstaatsanwaltschaft frankfurt
hat die ermittlungen übernommen
gegen 14.30 ist ein junger mann mit
seinem pkw
in eine gruppe des rosenmontagszuges
gefahren zeugen nach ersten
zeugenangaben vorsätzlich also es
scheint kein unfall geschehen zu sein
also wir wissen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
ist der teller 29 jahre alte symbol aus
dem umfeld volkmarsen statt
nein so motivlage kann ich ihnen noch
überhaupt nichts sagen
die polizei hat ein hinweis portal
eingerichtet zeugen werden gebeten
bilder und videos von der tat dort
hochzuladen sie nicht im netz zu
verbreiten und sich mit spekulationen
zurück zu halten
unser hessen korrespondent peter wagner
steht in ständigem kontakt mit der
polizei wie geht es den verletzten
sie sind wohl alle in medizinischer
versorgung in die krankenhäuser der
umgebung gebracht worden oder sie wurden
oder werden noch vor ort behandelt
es gab ja zum glück keine todesopfer und
obwohl mehrere menschen schwer verletzt
sind soll es ihnen trotzdem einigermaßen
so gehen dass weitere fälle nicht zu
befürchten sind
was wissen sie über den fahrer und sein
mögliches motiv
über das motiv weiß man zurzeit noch gar
nichts der mann ist nach dem was ich
höre nicht vernehmungsfähig er soll
entweder stark alkoholisiert sein oder
unter dem einfluss von drogen stehen
außerdem ist ja auch bei der fahrt bei
dem unfall selbst verletzt worden es ist
ein 29 jähriger aus volkmarsen und nach
den ersten erkenntnissen die die polizei
hat scheint es keinen politischen
hintergrund zu geben allerdings das habe
ich auch gerade gehört ist die wohnung
ist seine wohnung mittlerweile
durchsucht worden datenträger computer
sind beschlagnahmt
und jetzt wird mit hochdruck ermittelt
was möglicherweise als motiv hinter
dieser schrecklichen tat steht und auch
der hessische innenminister ist
mittlerweile auf dem weg nach volkmarsen
und wird sich nachher dort vor ort
selbst ein bild der lage machen
vielen dank für diese information
peterwagen zur politik die cdu ist
schwer unter druck in hamburg gestern
das schlechteste ergebnis bei einer
landtagswahl seit 70 jahren
die thüringen krise ungeklärt heute
haben die gremien entschieden
der neue parteichef wird nun doch schon
am 25 april gewählt wer antreten will
soll sich noch diese woche melden aus
berlin florian a
als ich das präsidium der cdu am morgen
trifft hat sich manche hoffnung schon
zerschlagen
zum beispiel die auf eine teamlösung es
wird nur funktionieren wenn nicht jeder
als bedingungen formuliert dass er die
nummer 1 ist offenbar aber wollte
niemand den noch nicht erklärten
bewerber zurück stecken weder friedrich
merz noch armin laschet oder jens spahn
und auch nicht norbert können und so
kann die noch-vorsitzende später nur an
datum verkünden
ein ausserordentlicher parteitag am 25
april soll entscheiden
diese wahl in acht wochen ist mehr als
nur die wahl eines bundesvorsitzenden
oder einer bundesvorsitzenden sondern
sie ist ein ganz klares präjudiz auch
für den kanzlerkandidaten oder die
kanzlerkandidatin der neue cdu-chef
sofort der nächste kanzlerkandidat das
veto aus münchen kommt postwendend
wir werden gemeinsam cdu und csu zu
gegebener zeit darüber befinden
mit wem wir dann in die bundestagswahl
ziehen werden dafür ist aber definitiv
jetzt noch nicht die zeit wo für heute
kaum zeit bleibt die verarbeitung der
cdu wahlpleite in hamburg mit
spitzenkandidat markus weinberg
stattdessen nutzt kramp karrenbauer die
pressekonferenz für einem scharfen
angriff auf spd-generalsekretär klingen
bei der hatte der cdu mehrfach
vorgeworfen sich zu wenig von der afg
abzugrenzen
entweder behauptet er damit dass die
gesamte führungsspitze der cdu lügt oder
er muss es für so unerträglich halten
mit der cdu zusammen zu arbeiten dass er
daneben die konsequenzen ziehen muss und
dann muss er mit seiner partei aus
dieser regierung aus dreht wenn ich
merke dass es in der cdu von teilen der
cdu annäherungsversuche an dfb geht
werde ich darauf hinweisen dass das
nicht in ordnung ist wie weiter in der
cdu als erster wagt sich offenbar
friedrich merz aus der deckung
pressekonferenz zur kandidatur für den
vorsitz
morgen vormittag theo koll in berlin
dann wirft er auch mal friedrich merz
als erster nach norbert röttgen seinen
hut in den ring
ja und wenn es wirklich morgen seine
kandidatur erklärung ist dann ist auch
damit klar es wird auf jeden fall zu
einer kampfkandidatur kommen denn
norbert röttgen hat sich ja schon
erklärt und damit ist definitiv jede
friedliche team regelung im vorfeld des
parteitags dann auch tot
die cdu wirkt getrieben wer hat
überhaupt die chance die partei da
rauszuholen so lange die kanzlerin noch
so präsent ist also auch wenn das jetzt
etwas spricht klingt das kann im grunde
nur die partei selbst egal wir in knapp
neun wochen gewählt wird er hat nur eine
chance wenn die cdu deutlich
geschlossener antritt als dass frau
kramp karrenbauer je erlebt hat aber
außer heeren erklärung deutet derzeit
nichts darauf hin die führungskrise
läuft munter weiter und der neue steht
nach dem parteitag dann ja für fast
anderthalb jahre in dem selben feuer in
dem auch frau kramp karrenbauer stand
also parteivorsitzender zu sein neben
einer kanzlerin die noch immer die
handlungsmacht hat und das
scheinwerferlicht bekommt auch deswegen
glaube ich will die csu den
kanzlerkandidaten erst in einem jahr
bestimmen und sollte der cdu-vorsitzende
bis dahin beschädigt sein dann gäbe es
ja immer noch den csu-vorsitzenden
letzteres ist natürlich blanke
spekulation dankeschön nach berlin theo
koll aus hamburg gibt es immer noch kein
vorläufiges amtliches endergebnis das
wahlverfahren ist kompliziert hier die
zahlen die bislang vorliegen
demnach kommt die spd auf 39 prozent die
grünen landen bei 24,2 prozent die cdu
11,2
die linke kommt auf 9,1 prozent die fdp
auf 5,3
die fdp liegt derzeit bei 5 prozent ein
teil der stimmen wurde ihr aber
versehentlich falsch zugeordnet so dass
die fdp möglicherweise nicht in die
bürgerschaft kommt christian hübscher
mit den reaktionen aus berlin dass die
fdp in hamburg immer noch bangen muss
liege auch am fehler von erfurt bedauert
parteichef lindner und will seine fdp
künftig wieder offensiv in der
politischen mitte verorten
auch als partei der politischen mitte
das bei vielen menschen der eindruck
entstanden ist dass die freien
demokraten keine klare grenzziehung
gegenüber der afg hätten auch die afg
hadert mit ihrem knappen abschneiden
macht dafür aber vor allem die anderen
verantwortlich nach thüringen und hanau
habe man nie dagewesene hetze und
ausgrenzung erlebt beklagt
bundestagsfraktionschef bauland wenn da
nicht abgerüstet wird dann weiß ich auch
nicht wie das mit der demokratie in
diesem land weitergehen
das gilt natürlich auch für uns auch wir
haben uns manchmal in der wortwahl
vergriffen
die bundes-spd weiß dass der sieg von
peter tschentscher wenig mit ihr zu tun
hat und lässt ihn allein heute glänzen
haben wir wirklich mal anlass zu feiern
ein großartiger erfolg für die spd nur
zweiter in hamburg und trotzdem die
großen gewinner
die grünen müssen sich daran gewöhnen
auch bundesweit groß zu denken
wir stehen derzeit an zweiter stelle mit
über 20 prozent und uns dann als dritter
oder kleinste oppositionskraft die bei
der letzten bundestagswahl wieder zu
sehen ich glaube dann hätte ich meinen
job ehrlich gesagt verfehlt auch die
linke sieht sich nach ihrem 9 prozent
erfolg bestätigt damit setzt sich ein
trend fort dass die linke in großen
städten mehr etablierte kraft ist ja
auch nach wie vor luft nach oben hat die
hamburg wahl zeigt wirkung in jeder
partei anders zum corona virus italien
sucht nach der nadel im heuhaufen und
die heißt patient sehr derjenige also
oder diejenigen die das virus nach
norditalien gebracht haben und womöglich
weiter menschen anstecken
bislang hatte sich das virus in europa
langsam ausgebreitet die fallzahlen
allesamt gering das hat sich nun
schlagartig geändert
italien zählt inzwischen rund 230
infektionen sechs patienten starben an
den folgen seit gestern sind mehrere
städte und dörfer abgeregelt die
weltgesundheitsorganisation beobachtet
die lage in italien genau und stellt
klar bisher gebe es keine weltweite
pandemie auch wenn die zahlen in
einzelnen ländern besorgniserregend sein
italiens nachbarländer sind in jedem
fall alarmiert österreich stoppte in der
nacht am brenner zwei züge am konto
checken berichtet dieser zug ist
unterwegs von italien nach deutschland
doch plötzlich wird der intercity am
brenner gestoppt zwei passagiere husten
stark und werden als corona
verdachtsfall eingestuft nach mehreren
stunden zwangsstopp ist klar falscher
alarm der zug darf weiter nach münchen
fahren
dieser fall zeigt wie angespannt die
situation ist zwar sei die lage unter
kontrolle aber wir müssen davon ausgehen
dass das virus weiter ausbreitet
natürlich auch in deutschland davon
müssen wir ausgehen
aber das wird dann natürlich wenn es
nach deutschland kommt wird es nicht wie
ein orkan innerhalb von zwei wochen
durch deutschland gehen sondern es wird
verschiedene regionen nacheinander
treffen
dafür seien die krankenhäuser in
deutschland gut vorbereitet sagt der
gesundheitsminister
ganze städte ab regeln wie in italien
sei auch hier möglich aber nicht geplant
man bisher noch nicht alles über das
neue corona virus klar sei aber dass
jeder einzelne etwas tun könne und das
virus einzudämmen
jeder kann einen beitrag leisten zu
seinem eigenen schutz und zum schutz der
mitbürger durch händewaschen durch
husten hygiene durch grippe impfung eine
impfung gegen das neue krone virus gibt
es bislang nicht und es wird wohl auch
noch bis ende des jahres dauern bis ein
impfstoff zur verfügung steht
das virus kann eine schwere
lungenkrankheit auslösen meistens
verläuft diese aber eher harmlos es ist
bei diesem virus ganz generell so dass
es sehr milde symptome macht bei den
allermeisten menschen und wir wissen
inzwischen dass patienten mit dieser
milden symptomatik schon infektiös sein
können und deswegen fordern experten das
flächendeckender kontrolliert wird 16
bestätigte fälle gibt es bislang in
deutschland diese zahl wird wohl noch
weiter steigen
weitere informationen rund um das corona
virus haben die kollegen von wiso direkt
im anschluss jederzeit auf dem laufenden
halten wir sie auf heute.de und
beantworten fragen welche symptome es
gibt und wie gefährlich das virus ist
us-präsident jump ist in indien und wird
bei seinem ersten staatsbesuch dort für
ein umfassendes handelsabkommen mit
premierminister modi will er in den
nächsten zwei tagen vor allem über die
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und ein
milliardenschweres rüstungsgeschäft
sprechen
die usa sehen indien als wichtiges
gegengewicht zur wirtschaftsmacht china
der besuch der weltkulturerbestätte taj
mahal wurde von protesten gegen den us
präsidenten begleitet
urteil im fall des früheren hollywood
produzenten harvey meinst ihn wegen
vergewaltigung und schwerer sexueller
nötigung ist er schuldig gesprochen
worden
das teilte die staatsanwaltschaft in new
york mit in zwei anklagepunkten wegen
wiederholter sexueller angriffe wurde
der 67-jährige dagegen freigesprochen
seit 2017 hatten mainz den mehr als 80
frauen sexuelle übergriffe vorgeworfen
und da fragen wir nach war johannes hano
in new york was bedeutet dieses urteil
jetzt für mein stil
ich glaube man kann die bedeutung dieses
urteils gar nicht hoch genug einschätzen
die staatsanwaltschaft hat sich gerade
zu der aussage hinreißen lassen dass
dieses urteil den lauf der geschichte
verändert habe das besondere nämlich ist
dass die geschworenen den beiden opfern
geglaubt haben obwohl es weder zeugen
noch beweise gegeben hat mainz team
hatte immer wieder behauptet jeglicher
6er einvernehmlich gewesen
seine anwälte haben versucht die
zeuginnen unglaubwürdig zu machen indem
man e-mails präsentiert aus denen
hervorging dass die beiden opfer auch
jahrelangen nach den vergewaltigung noch
intime enge beziehung zu wein steen
hatten aber diesen weg ist die jury
nicht mitgegangen weins dahin wartet
jetzt also erst mit handschellen aus dem
gericht abgeführt worden wartet jetzt
auf das strafmaß verkündung des könnten
fünf bis 25 jahre sein
er will in berufung gehen aber egal wie
es jetzt ausgehen das ist wie noch lange
nicht vorbei denn in los angeles warten
schon zwei weitere verfahren hoffen
dankeschön noch new yorkerin ist hanno
für die einen ist er ein held für die
anderen ein verräter wikileaks gründer
julien assange ab heute klärt ein
gericht in london ob großbritannien den
48-jährigen an die usa ausliefert die
hintergründe
2010 wird assange für die us-regierung
zum staatsfeind er veröffentlichte
geheime us-dokumente zu mutmaßlichen
kriegsverbrechen 2012 flüchtet er in die
botschaft ecuadors in london um eine
auslieferung an die usa zu entgehen
im april 2009 10 nach fast sieben jahren
in der botschaft lässt ecuador assange
fallen die britische polizei verhaftet
ihn seitdem sitzt er in einem
hochsicherheitsgefängnis aus london mit
früh am morgen erschienen die ersten
besucher vor dem gericht im osten
londons wo die anhörung in anwesenheit
assange begann im gerichtssaal sind
keine filmaufnahmen gestattet im letzten
jahr hatten britische polizisten assange
aus der ecuadorianischen botschaft in
london gezerrt und verhaftet das gericht
soll nun entscheiden ob er an die usa
ausgeliefert wird wohl im fall einer
verurteilung bis zu 175 jahre haft
drohen
internationale unterstützer
menschenrechtsorganisationen und
journalistenverbände fordern seine
sofortige freilassung
assange habe nur seine arbeit als
journalist gemacht und
menschenrechtsverletzungen der usa
öffentlich dokumentiert die trump
regierung so der vorwurf wolle an
assange ein exempel statuieren um
kritische journalisten und whistleblower
weltweit einzuschüchtern
wir sollten die menschenrechte
verteidigen für das recht auf
journalismus eintreten ungeachtet der
person um die es hier geht
zum auftakt hörte das gericht heute die
anträge der us amerikanischen seite
morgen werden assange anwälte ihre
argumente vorliegen
das verfahren könnte sich nach angaben
von experten über monate hinziehen
wir haben diese sendung mit dem begonnen
was in volkmarsen an diesem rosenmontag
passiert ist jetzt möchten wir ihnen
aber auch noch zeigen wie
hunderttausende vor der nachricht aus
volkmarsen diesen runden montag erlebt
haben
es wurde gefeiert und position bezogen
wie hier in mainz zur klimapolitik der
kanzlerin und in düsseldorf wo ihre
gehandelten nachfolger im rampenlicht
standen ebenfalls thema
das führungsduo der spd und auch das ist
karneval 2020 der dom weint und köln
erinnert an den rassistischen anschlag
in hanau norbert und jetzt kommst du ja
mit dem sport und zunächst der champions
league bleibt sich und dortmund haben in
der vergangenen woche ihre hinspiele
gewonnen
morgen wird sich der fc bayern eine gute
ausgangsposition im achtelfinale
verschaffen heute das letzte training
dahoam vor dem auswärtsspiel beim fc
chelsea
ein ständchen zum 55 hansi flick beginn
seinen geburtstag beim münchner
abschlusstraining hinter hohen
sichtschutzwänden nur 15 minuten war zu
sehen erlaubt leon goretzka nach
verletzung wieder dabei und natürlich
robert lewandowski vor dem sie bei
chelsea respekt haben er ist einer der
besten stürmer der welt hat das mehrfach
bewiesen und vorfall schlechten tag wie
gegen chelsea hatten die bayern 2012 das
champions league finale daheim verloren
damals dabei frank lampard heute trainer
bei den momentan formschwachen london an
ich habe das spiel damals vom fernsehen
verfolgt ich habe noch erinnerungen
daran
hoffen wir dass es dieses mal ein
besseres ende nimmt einen start wie im
vorjahr in die ko phase wollen die
bayern nicht noch mal erleben da kam
gleich das aus gegen den fc liverpool
ehemalige eishockey-bundestrainer uwe
krupp soll den kölner haien wieder das
siegen beibringen als nachfolger des
entlassenen mark stewart die kölner
haben in der de l 17 spiele nacheinander
verloren und bundestagspräsident
wolfgang schäuble ist von ioc präsident
thomas bach heute in lausanne der
olympische orden verliehen worden
schäubles engagement für den sport ziehe
sich wie ein roter faden durch seine
vita betonte thomas bach in der
laudation vor 40 jahren hatte der
fechter und damalige athletensprecher
und der politiker schäuble noch verbal
die klingen gekreuzt in der diskussion
um den olympia boykott 1980 neun jahre
später initiierte schäuble das programm
integration durch sport und das ist auch
heute ein erfolgsmodell dankeschön
norbert das wetter bleibt für die
meisten nass und stürmisch mehr dazu hat
gleich ist intern das heute journal um
viertel vor zehn mit claus kleber morgen
begrüßt sie hier christian sievers wir
danken für ihr interesse wünschen ihnen
noch einen friedlichen abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter noch einmal milde
luft gibt es mit tief sera und das wird
hauptsächlich in den süden gelenkt
ansonsten kommt morgen im tagesverlauf
dann kühlere luft von nordwesten
reingezogen
das wird auch in den nächsten tagen
allmählich kühler schauen wir erstmal
die kommende nacht und da gibt es regen
aus südwestlichen richtungen dazu auch
kräftiger wind teils mit stürmischen
böen oder sturmböen
ganz im norden kann es auch einige
schneeflocken bereits geben ganz im
süden bleibt es dagegen trocken mit
temperaturen von 1 grad im südosten
deutschlands und 9 grad im
rhein-main-gebiet morgen im tagesverlauf
weitere schauer von südwesten her
teilweise recht windig im norden sogar
stürmisch und auch einige trockene
abschnitte nach osten hin sind dabei die
temperaturen erreichen dabei höchste
werte von 6 grad in schleswig holstein
und bis zu 13 grad im südosten
die nächsten tage am mittwoch kommen
schauinsland mit kühlerer luft teils mit
gewittern noch werte bis 1 bis 7 grad
donnerstag ähnliches programm teilweise
mit schnee im süden ja auch mal liegen
bleiben kann damit ein schöner abend